roseann is back with vengeance
journalism collapses on all sides and
senator ted cruz stops by so we got a
big show for you i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
I do have many many many thoughts on the
Roseanne premier it had huge ratings who
will get into all of that I do think
it's an important cultural moment but
not quite in the way that I think a lot
of Republicans want it to be a huge
cultural moment first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at
trippin comm so when you plan a vacation
finding a place to stay that will make
everybody happy is usually really
difficult particularly for the right
price and if you have a family this is
certainly true right if you have small
kids and you're staying in a one-bedroom
a hotel room it is just as a stress
which is why you need trippin calm
because tripping calm lets you compare
every home from the world's top vacation
rental sites in one place to find the
best deal on your perfect vacation
rental my wife and I only use vacation
rentals now we need a kitchenette so
there are kitchens that we can actually
cook and we need a couple of bedrooms
that we can sleep because otherwise our
kids will keep us up the entire night
and scream at us so this is what ripping
calm is for vacation rentals are better
we're talking more privacy more space
for everyone under one roof you really
haven't experienced a great vacation
until you've done one outside of a hotel
room and instead go onto tripping calm
and got into vacation rental a home away
from home again
washer/dryer if you're a parent you're
young parents or you just you don't want
to pack that heavily you don't want to
bring a week's worth of clothes just
want to bring two days wear the clothes
you need the washer/dryer well tripping
back on make sure that you have all of
these meta matisse best of all a trip at
tripping Calm
you can join the millions of travelers
to find more savings with rates up to
80% less than traditional hotel rooms so
if you're planning Spring Break on the
beach in Florida it's stripping calm it
doesn't matter if we going to Lake Tahoe
they trippin calm is everywhere and this
year's save time and money when you book
the vacation home of your dreams trippin
comm slash appear oh that's TR IPP ing
comm slash up hero trippin comm slash
appear use that slash up heroes they
know that we sent you and find your
perfect vacation rental okay so the big
news of the night was cultural news
so Roseanne Barr is back she'd been
absent from the public scene for about
20 years Roseanne actually went off the
air the show Roseanne went off the air
in 1997 so it's been 21 years since
Roseanne Barr was on the air with a
regular sitcom she did some reality TV
stuff but she wasn't world-famous
anymore and now she's back in she is
back with a vengeance because the
ratings on her show were just
unbelievable
looking at the ratings right now on
Roseanne's show the revival of Roseanne
premiered to a massive ratings we're
talking from Entertainment Weekly an
impressive five point one rating which
is
almost unheard of it is the highest
rated comedy telecast on any network in
nearly four years since the premiere
episode of The Big Bang Theory from 2014
18 point 2 million viewers among adults
18 to 49 which means it was even more
for older episodes obviously so this was
bigger than this is us during any of its
regularly scheduled episodes in the
adult demo it Trump's Sundays 60 minutes
episode with stormy Daniels it's amazing
right it's yeah it actually was higher
among total viewers then it's 1997
finale 21 years ago and the audience
grew slightly from the first quarter to
its second which is a pretty good sign
this was Tuesday's highest-rated
entertainment telecast in six years
among young adults and ABC's best
results in the timeslot since 2006 okay
that is a massive massive hit for ABC if
those ratings hold up for Roseanne know
what's fascinating about this is a lot
of people on the right are very excited
about this this is the cultural moment
right because Roseanne Barr is a Trump
supporter and Roseanne's character in
the show is a Trump supporter she talks
about how she voted for Trump in the
very first episode but a note of caution
Roseanne is not a conservative show it's
not even close to a conservative show in
fact I think it's pretty clever and
nefarious in how non conservative it is
and it's worth going back to the history
of Roseanne and talking a little bit
about this I happen to be an expert on
this because I wrote an entire 400 page
book about television called primetime
propaganda in which I talked with the
producers of the original Roseanne
including Marcy Carsey who is the woman
behind it originally and the way you can
tell that this this show has some pretty
skewed politics even though it has a
trump supporter who's not being
portrayed as a complete and income pop
the reason you can tell if the politics
of the show are skewed is because the
New York Times is treating it well
voxcom treating it well right all of the
leftist publications are saying Roseanne
is great why because the actual theme of
the show is that the only reason you
would vote for Trump is for non cultural
reasons right the show is one big lie
about Trump this shows one big lie about
conservatives they lie that the show
tells is that the reason people voted
for Trump is because they were
dissatisfied with the economy and
because they were looking to give Donald
Trump a chance to fix it and it wasn't
about cultural issues that's not true
okay in 2016 Donald Trump did not win
because there was a bunch of
dispossessed of white people who decided
they need a better way of doing
economics and so they turn to Trump
that's not what
what happened is that culture war was at
the front of everyone's mind 2016 was a
cultural war everyone knew it as a
culture were over race and over feminism
and the left knows this too and what
they're trying to suggest is that the
only conciliation that can take place in
the country can take place on economic
issues now this is how Hollywood views
politics it's very important to know
this show is produced in Hollywood right
okay this is supposed to be a show about
the Midwest and a downtrodden family in
Ohio or somesuch but the reality is that
the politics of this are pure Hollywood
in Hollywood you are allowed to be
libertarian you are not allowed to be
socially conservative in Hollywood if
you say listen I have a Republican
because I want lower taxes people sort
of nod they go okay
fair enough or if you say listen Hillary
was a bad candidate I just wanted to
give Trump a shot because I thought
maybe he could do something on the
economy
everybody says all right kind of get it
that's okay I can handle it there are a
couple things you are not allowed to say
in Hollywood those things that you are
not allowed to say our boy is a boy and
a girl is a girl you're not allowed to
say this in Hollywood you will lose your
job if you say that transgenderism is a
mental disorder you'll lose your job in
Hollywood you're not allowed to say that
for example same-sex marriage is not
traditional marriage and they're not the
same thing and they're not of equal
moral value if you say that in Hollywood
you will absolutely lose your job you'll
never work again in in Hollywood in this
industry if you say things like abortion
is wrong and abortion is a sin and
abortion is murder if you say that sort
of stuff in Hollywood you will not work
again I remember I interviewed Patti
Heaton who's very pro-life and I asked
her Patti do you think that you've lost
jobs because of your conservatism and I
remember she first said to me no I don't
think so and then she called me back 24
hours later so I called around I found
out I lost six specific jobs because of
my my pro-life positions so the way
Hollywood works this is sure we can be
conciliatory sure we can reach across
the aisle sure we can have American
unity again but only if you accept our
social agenda and that's what Rosanna
was really about and this is why the New
York Times is propping up Rosie on the
show okay again the show was funny okay
you can you can watch well-written just
like a lot of shows on TV it's
well-written and I think that folks in
the middle of the country who are
finally feeling like wow now I'm finally
getting my respect because there's a pro
Trump character who's not perceived as a
complete jerk is on TV fair enough but
if you think that this show is not a
left show you're wrong it is a left show
okay so here's what the New York Times
had to say about this when we last saw a
rose n Connor
1997 the character was sitting alone on
that old living room couch after
revealing that her husband Dan had died
of a heart attack
and that online seasons of Roseanne had
been a grief induced fantasy about her
family or something like that
now Rosanna's back the fantasy is out
and Trump is in the show's emmy-winning
star Roseanne Barr returns Tuesday night
to ABC with a 9 episode revival season
Dan is back to once again played by John
Goodman as his daughter Darlene Sara
Gilbert who's also an executive producer
and much of the original cast and here's
what the New York Times gets it okay
here's what the New York Times has to
say about the original Roseanne quote
Roseanne was a bonafide trailblazer the
first time around with its focused on
blue-collar Americans its diversity of
LGBT characters and its star a woman who
did not look or sound like a typical
television female lead the new Roseanne
is topical in its own ways starting with
Roseanne Connors full-throated support
for president Trump miss bars a trump
backer as well to the dismay of many
fans she argued on Jimmy Kimmel recently
that supporting mr. Trump was critical
to keeping my prince from the presidency
so resin bar is not a typical Trump
supporter okay the vast majority of
people who voted for Trump many of them
are more fond of pence than they are of
Trump in terms of his policies even if
they like Trump's pugnacious persona so
it is worth noting that the real reason
that the media are supporting this is
because the original character of
Roseanne Barr was not a conservative
character I know this because I talked
to the people who created it so Marcy
Carsey is the person who helped create
the show here is what she told me back
when I wrote primetime propaganda in
2011 quote you know I'm of a liberal
bent so obviously that's gonna come out
of the shows I was involved with I was
raised in a moderate Republican
Eisenhower Republican family I'm very
much a Democrat but I understand people
that have that kind of bent she says
when we did Roseanne the intent was to
show about them to do a show about the
millions the 85% of households out there
where the woman had to work not an upper
class or upper middle class choice to
work but where the woman has to work the
woman should be under educated should be
not wealthy should be natively smart a
working-class heroine to represent the
difficult lives that so many millions of
people were leading so NBC rejected the
initial concept they said that Roseanne
was a fat woman nobody's gonna watch
theirs according to Marcy Carsey
and so they brought it over to ABC
Brandon Stoddard at ABC was the guy who
who helps push it he said I'll never
forget this as long as I lived I showed
the pilot to the affiliates there were a
thousand and the wives and I'm scared to
death I mean it was really really risky
it was against the grain I also needed
to hit really bad and I thought this
could be it I was standing in the back
of the room where there were a thousand
people and the women are invited to
watch it and the thing is playing
they're laughing laughing laughing and
she makes a speech somewhere about I'm
I'm supposed to be a lover I'm supposed
to be a friend I'm supposed to be taking
care of the teacher I'm handing out the
food tonight she does the confuse to my
role which Roseanne's had brilliantly
and there was audible reaction by the
women in the audience audible they were
like yeah and I went we've got a hit man
they completely got it because we were
real here's the point
the Roseanne's character it could have
been a Bernie Sanders supporter just as
easily as a trump supporter in this show
because this is a class-based show it is
not a moral based show it is not a
traditionally moral based shows not a
traditional morality show the idea here
is that Roseanne is blue-collar and her
family is blue-collar and she doesn't
like elites that's the appeal of the
show so it's a very populist show in the
sort of classical populist sense and
there's no reason why she wouldn't have
voted for Bernie Sanders in the last
election cycle in the primaries as
opposed to Trump per se which is a
dramatic miss Reid on who the Trump
voters are which again I'm going to
explain in just a second Roseanne's
original show as the New York Times says
it was very Pro LGBT right it did it in
vibes all of the values of the of
Hollywood he was basically an Archie
Bunker character who happened to be on
the left right a grumpy quote-unquote
blue-collar conservative who wasn't
actually very conservative at all right
in one episode of the original series
Roseanne told her daughters Arlene to
use birth control even the daughter
wasn't even though the daughter wasn't
yet having sex there's another episode
in which Charlene admitted to using pot
speed and acid there was an episode in
which Roseanne Sun achieves a certain
physical status for his genitals and she
says what about pitching the trouser
tent booting up the hard drive charming
the anaconda I mean this was a very very
vulgar show and the show was designed to
be vulgar
it was vulgar for liberalism sake the
most famous episode was one called Don't
Ask Don't Tell in which Roseanne visits
a lesbian bar with her friend Nancy and
this kiss financed his girlfriend and
Frank Rich in the New York Times of
course praised it so remember this thing
was a critical hit because the idea was
that people in the middle America
actually have the same values as people
in Hollywood they just have different
economic priorities that is the lie that
Roseanne tells John Goodman's character
is constantly portrayed in the original
series and in this series as well the
first couple of episodes as basically a
an idiot right he's a dolt
who's kind hearted Roseanne's really the
boss of the place and you know they used
to show his butt crack all the time I
national TV just to demonstrate how dumb
John Goodman actually was he was kind of
the belly he's sort of the proto Homer
Simpson
I read around the time Homer Simpson was
coming around who's all about class
warfare
it was posed as a sort of political show
but it's a it's a politics of the left
it's a politics left and I'm gonna
explain how that plays into the couple
of episodes of Roseanne that premiered
last night because it really is quite
fascinating and again demonstrates if
this show is a cultural reach out to
conservatives but undercuts virtually
every conservative belief about social
morality in in almost every sense okay
so first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at thrive market so to
look at me you would say look at that
man that man has the body of a Greek god
well you know how that happened that
happens because I eat healthy
hey I eat healthy and one of the ways I
eat healthy is by shopping over at
thrive market it's a revolutionary
online marketplace on a mission to make
healthy living easy and affordable for
everyone you can shop for thousands of
the best selling non-gmo foods and
natural products always at twenty five
to fifty percent below traditional
retail prices you can check out the
thrive brand market price of a market
brand products because they are the
highest quality ingredients and even
more affordable prices than the current
premium products carry down site now you
asked me Ben what can you eat there well
the answer is that they have kosher food
there because you can filter the
catalogue by your value by your values
and dietary preference so you can filter
it by paleo gluten-free vegan kosher
ketogenic you can shop for 90 plus
values also including non-gmo
sustainably farmed Fairtrade certified
bpa free and more and more in just one
click of a button no more reading labels
because thrive market does all of the
homework for you which is just fantastic
more than 70% of the thrive market
catalog by the way cannot be found on
Amazon so go check it out you don't want
to hang out in the parking lot with all
those people driving Priuses and and
shouting about how they love Jill Stein
over at the Whole Foods you don't want
to overpay at Whole Foods
instead go over to thrive market here's
how it works okay users get 20 $20 off
their first three orders at 49 bucks or
more plus free shipping pretty solid
deal most shoppers spend more than 49
bucks on the site anyway do the math you
spend 49 bucks and thrive automatically
gives you back $20 so your total
purchase price becomes 30 bucks and you
get that deal three times in a row when
you go to thrive market calm slash up
here oh that's thrive market calm slash
appear you get your instant 60 bucks of
free groceries thrive market calm slash
Shapiro three orders and 49 bucks or
more you get 20 bucks off each time it's
just fantastic you're gonna be eating
healthier your family's gonna be eating
healthier and you get to skip that line
at Whole Foods we're sitting next to the
lady who's jabbering on about how much
she enjoys
environmental music so check it out
thrive market calm @ / Pierrot the
healthy food without all the hassle
thrive market calm / Shapiro ok so back
to Roseanne and this cultural moment
because a lot of people are saying this
is the big cultural moment in the United
States so here is that what the first
two episodes are about first episode is
about Roseanne arguing with her sister
about Trump versus Hillary and it turns
out that her sister voted for Jill Stein
that's the big punchline is that the
sister was in fact convinced by Roseanne
that Hillary was so bad that she had to
vote for Jill Stein and she feels like
she threw her vote away and it turns out
that can they get along when Roseanne
and her sister sure they can get along
because they're not arguing over deep
issues they're just arguing over you
know things like economics the real
reason that Roseanne voted for Trump is
because the economy was bad because she
felt like maybe give Trump a chance and
the real reason that this this sister
voted instead for Jill Stein is be aware
where Hillary Clinton is because she
cares so much about health care right
there not really any deep differences
between us you understand the deep
differences on cultural issues and
morality and values those don't exist
there are only issues between us is how
Hollywood thinks the only issue is
between us our interpretations of
economic data this is how we're gonna
come together again there's only one
problem we're now coming together around
that because the second episode of the
show I mean it's mentioned in the first
episode of the show is that Darlene's
sons Arlene is of course the president's
daughter in the show her son is named
Mark and he likes to dress up in girls
clothing right but here's here's what
the producer said it would be wrong to
assume that the nine-year-old character
is transitioning or gay so they asked
executive producer Sarah Gilbert to
explain why she created the role of Mark
so they asked does mark see himself as a
girl Sarah Gilbert said he doesn't
that's something that got out of the
press that's not true he's not a
transgender character he's a little boy
he's based on a few kids in my life that
are boys who dressing more traditionally
feminine clothing he's too young to be
gay and he doesn't identify as
transgender but he just likes wearing
that kind of clothing and that's where
he is at this point in his life
hey these are the kinds of values that
people actually voted for Trump
regarding okay they felt like there was
a cramdown in Hollywood saying that you
are not allowed to raise your kids with
traditional gender roles and that if you
do it's mean and nasty and cruel right
one of the reasons that people voted for
Trump is the cultural blowback it's
because Trump is a cultural warrior
Donald Trump doesn't give a damn about
economics outside of tariffs down the
Trump doesn't know anything about
economics outside of tariffs but what
Donald Trump does know is that there is
a large feeling in the rest of the
United States but the
values of New York and Los Angeles are
actually not popular and we feel like
they're being crammed down our throats
so what is rosie and zu Roseanne
features a seven-year-old kid who is
dressing in female clothing and
everybody around the house is going
that's okay honey that's fine honey and
when John Goodman interject and he says
well maybe that's not so fine
they don't give him a good argument
instead what they say is well I'm just
afraid he's gonna go to school and get
beat up here's a good argument okay it
is not healthy to avoid reinforcing
certain gender roles it is not a healthy
thing for children to be confused about
gender okay the left wants to make a
couple of arguments with regard to
cross-dressing for children one of the
arguments they wanna make is what
difference does it make all clothes are
equal who does it really bother well if
that's the case then why do you care if
I put my kids in corduroy slacks versus
putting them in a dress well you're
saying is my kid should be able to wear
the dress and it shouldn't be up to me
whether I want my kid to wear corduroy
slacks so clearly you think the clothes
make a difference okay and then there's
the other issue they say well you know
what's traditionally feminine about what
makes clothes feminine or masculine may
now obviously you go to Ireland and
they're guys wearing kilts those are
basically skirts isn't that feminine the
answer is every society in human history
has had traditional male and female garb
virtually every society in the history
of humanity has had traditionally male
and female garb because that is one of
the ways that you inculcate boys into
being men is by saying that you are in
fact a little man right you are one day
going to dress like a man you're one day
going to be a man and that means that
you should be trained in being a man you
shouldn't train to be a girl you
shouldn't train to be like your mom when
it comes to dressing it's one of the
reasons that the Bible is very strict
about cross-dressing actually but the
notion here is that traditional
conservatives don't really exist that
really they're all fine with their 7
year-olds dressing up in dresses and if
they're really tolerant they would be
what makes Roseann and John good men
good people is that they're allowing the
seven-year-old to run around in a dress
and if they didn't allow that 7
year-olds run around in a dress then
that would mean that they were mean
right by the end of the episode John
Goodman has fully accepted this and this
is not actually the only socially left
point that's made in Rosia Roseanne also
makes another socially left point so
back in the day when they originally
premiered Roseanne Roseanne was a very
pro-abortion character in fact she even
that considers aborting her child
and one of her kids in the later
episodes of Roseanne and one of the
things that happens in this series is
that Roseanne won't Rose and other
daughter not Darlene comes back she
comes home
and she has decided that she wants to be
a surrogate and she wants to carry
somebody else's child fine
but now Roseann finds out that her
daughter actually wants to use her own
eggs to be a surrogate so this would
actually be Roseanne's grandchild right
and Roseanne says well wait a second
that's my grandkid and then the her
daughter makes an argument the argument
my body my choice in auras and says you
know what you're right
your body your choice okay that really
isn't an argument about surrogacy that's
an argument about abortion they just
don't want to make an abortion argument
because it turns out that abortion is
not nearly as popular a political stance
in 2018 as it was in 1997 so all of this
is designed again to shovel a bunch of
social left messaging into a supposedly
conservative friendly show so in many
ways it's actually more disturbing from
a conservative points of view than
openly left shows like Will and Grace
because Will and Grace just says what
they think if they just say
conservatives are a bunch of nasty rubes
who hate gay people and and will make
fun of them all the time this show says
listen Trump supporters are really all
like us they're all social leftists
right deep down inside they're all
social leftists right they're people who
like abortion they like cross-dressing
and they're fine with with early stage
transgenderism they're fine with all of
these things right it's just that they
disagree on economics and that's how
we're gonna come together now that
actually achieves the same purpose as
Will and Grace
right because Will and Grace says
conservatives who believe all this stuff
about same-sex marriage and
transgenderism and abortion those people
are rubes and Hicks and evil people
Roseanne is almost saying the same thing
she's just saying it backwards she's
just saying real conservatives don't
care about those issues I mean if they
were to care about this issues wow those
people would be awful or if they were to
say to the seven-year-old boy yo son
don't put on a pair of slacks your son
take off the sequins if they were to say
that's their kid if the father were to
step in and say listen I think it's
important that you dress like a man
because one day you will be a man and
being a man is important and there are
certain cultural totems that that show
that you want to be a man and that
you're growing up to be a man a
responsible man cross-dressing is not
part of that right if if you were to say
that to a child in the national
television this would make you cruel
inhumane nasty barbaric right because
these are the values the left wants to
push so you end up in the same place
with this wink and nod with this wink
and nod to the notion that they're
actually pro Trump or Trump friendly and
that just isn't really the case okay
there Trump friendly in name only
but again their Trump friendly because
they think that poor people will vote
for Trump or Bernie because they're poor
and downtrodden not because those poor
downtrodden people actually may have
values and go to certain biblical values
and go to church and think that
Hollywood cramming down Laverne Cox on
the rest of the country and suggesting
that if you don't think that a man is a
girl and a girl is man that you're a bad
person is a bad thing so it's it's a
pretty it's a pretty amazing thing that
Roseanne is attempting to do and this is
unfortunately how so much it left is is
working these days another indicator of
how the left is working these days so
Kevin Williamson is a columnist over at
National Review one of my favorite
columnist actually terrific writer real
sort of my kind of class writes things
that are that are you know brilliant and
also kooky but he's just been hired by
the Atlantic it's really interesting go
back to Sunday and last Sunday I was not
at brian Stelter and brian Stelter asked
me about the brian Stelter asked me
about if i was criticizing the media all
the time why didn't i attempt to join
the mainstream media outlet and I said
would you hire me and he sort of laughs
because the answer is of course he and
then is not going to be in the business
of hiring me you know they have my phone
number I've met with people over at
Siena and these are not folks who are
probably going to call me up and ask me
to do a show even though this show right
here it gets better ratings than pretty
much anything else they have in daytime
okay but they're not gonna do that Kevin
Williamson is just another indicator of
why so Kevin Williamson was very very
anti-trump I mean Kevin Williamson calls
Trump sons Uday and COO say hey Kevin
Williamson has talked about he called
Donald Trump an ape on an escalator when
when Donald Trump announced for the
presidency Woodson could not be more
anti Trump it is not possible from be
more anti Trump and now the Atlantic
wants to hire him and now the Atlantic
is getting tremendous blowback they're
getting tremendous blowback because
Kevin Williamson has a couple of really
kind of odd positions he has a position
saying that he is that he is in favor of
the death penalty for women who actually
obtain abortions for example and this is
unacceptable the Atlantic's okay to have
people like Peter Bernard where openly
Pro Hamas but it's another thing for
Kevin Williamson to make an argument
that I think is wrong but at least is is
sort of interesting even if it's if you
don't I think it's morally wrong where I
disagree with them but the idea is you
can't have people who disagree with you
over at the end lansac so the entire
left has decided Kevin Williamson is not
allowed to work at the Atlantic and
they're trying to force the
like not to hire him there's a big piece
by Sarah Jones over the New Republic in
which she links Kevin Williamson's
controversial sections with his
non-controversial sections right when
William says she says how dared the
Atlanta Claire Williamson when William
says Williamson says things like Laverne
Cox had amputated her genitals and that
she's an effigy of and that she is an
effigy of a woman well Laverne Cox
didn't have you Tate his genitals I mean
there's there's no question that that's
what happened I mean uh vaginoplasty is
in amputation of the penis I mean that's
just what it is there's no other way to
put it but you know again the idea here
is that any conservative cannot be hired
by a left outlet or a mainstream media
outlet just won't happen there's a
really interesting thought experiment
experiment by a guy named Jo Rosenberg
on Twitter he asked people on the left
okay fine you don't want Williamson
named a conservative they would be okay
with the Atlantic High ring and people
could come up with no names because
those names do not exist the way that
the left defines the right is people who
agree with us right that's how rosy on
defines people on people who voted for
Trump they're people who agree with us
they just disagree about Hillary's
thinking that's not what happened in
this last election cycle there are
serious real differences between right
and left and you're not actually gonna
get to any serious sense of American
unity without coming face-to-face with
those differences instead of just
eliding them and pretending we all agree
that seven-year-old children should be
whereas seven-year-old boys should be
wearing girls clothing okay before we go
any further
zip recruiter com so zip recruiters a
common you want to get the best
employees this is the place to go so zip
recruiter comm knows there's a smart way
to recruit people and they built a
platform that finds the right job
candidates for you they learn what
you're looking for they identify people
with the right experience and they
invite them to apply to your job in fact
80% of employers who post a job on zip
recorder to get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day zip
recorder by the way does not stop there
they even spot like the strongest
applications you receive so you never
miss a great match the right candidates
are out there and zip recruiter is how
you find them businesses of all sizes
you zip recruit we use if recruiter here
at the Daily wire and you can use zip
recruiter right now for free try it for
free at zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that's zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire again a zip recruiter comm
slash daily wear when you use the daily
wire then you are able to post a job for
free and check it out and again
80% of all employers who post a job on
zip recruiter comm get a quality
candidate through the site in just one
day it's the best way to up your game at
your business get rid of the employees
who aren't doing their job
supplant them with employees who are or
your spit your staffing up you need to
find new people
zip recruiter comm is the place to go
zip recruiter again comm slash daily why
are you slash daily wire so they know we
sent you
zip recruiter is the smartest way to
hire okay so yesterday we had the
opportunity to talk with senator Ted
Cruz and I want to jump right into this
because a bit of a long interview so the
Senators stop by here's what it sounded
like all right well so joining me is
Senator Ted Cruz senator Cruz thanks so
much for taking the time it's very cool
they're out in Los Angeles and you know
welcome to the show
well thanks Ben great to be with you
well so let me start by asking you about
the omnibus package he's obviously that
just passed a lot of conservatives very
unhappy about it you voted against the
omnibus package why did it pass whose
fault is it where should we have our
pitchforks you know look the omnibus is
a total mess it's 1.3 trillion in
spending it grows the debt it grows the
deficit it grows just about every part
of the federal government and it really
is it's it's a product of the swamp
the thing is 2,200 pages and it was
written in the dark of night it was
written by really four people by Mitch
McConnell Chuck Schumer Paul Ryan and
Nancy Pelosi the other members of
Congress we didn't even get to see it
until hours before we vote so so I can
promise you there is not a senator alive
who's read all 2,200 pages of it I don't
I don't think any of the for suppose it
authors of it I'm ray don't play 200
pages of it and so the Democrats price
for agreeing to anything is grow
government massively and and not
accomplished conservative principles and
unfortunately an awful lot of
Republicans in Washington rolled over to
greet with so we were told that there
was gonna be regular order when
Republicans got back into power who's
the big obstacle here because it looks
like the house is able to pass some of
these bills through a regular order but
it seems like everything stops dead in
the Senate well look in the Senate we
had no amendments on the bill there were
a number of us Michael E and I were both
pressing with how about have it opened
for amendments and our leadership says
no no that's not practical it's not
feasible because we've cut a deal with
Chuck Schumer and if you have an
amendment an amendment might take out
one of Chuck Schumer's priorities and
then our deal is gone the system is a
corrupt practice now I will say I think
there were some meaningful victories and
things we were able to keep out of the
bomb the bus there was a big
hard push from from a number of more
moderate and liberal Republicans to have
tens of billions of dollars of bailouts
for insurance companies under Obamacare
I think that would have been a disaster
the idea that we're bailing out the
insurance companies who are making
record profits while not honoring our
promise to repeal Obamacare while not
lowering premiums reducing regulations
expanding choice expanding freedom
I think that's nuts and and we had a big
battle in the conference I pressed very
hard to keep the insurance company
bailouts out of the bill and we
succeeded we kept him out so I mean as a
conservatives I spent virtually my
entire life being frustrated with the
Republican Party because the Republican
Party makes a bunch of promises about
thinking they're gonna do we gave them
the house we give the Senate we got in
the presidency and then very little of
it gets done and when it does get done
it tends to be done in these vast bills
that are a thousand pages long and
always are perhaps yeah and which is the
problem here that Republicans are
promising more than they can deliver or
is the problem here that the crowd of
conservatives we're just not realistic
about what is possible in a Senate with
51 votes and with you know a couple of
Republicans who are best very dicey on
serious conservative priorities so is it
an expectation problem or is it a
promise problem so I actually think it's
neither I think the problem is our
leadership is not focused on delivering
on our promises and and having a
systematic plan to accomplish that look
back at 2017 2017 despite all of the
political craziness you and I are both
aware of all the craziness in Washington
mm-hmm despite that we accomplished a
remarkable amount I think the four big
priorities for 2017 were tax reform
regulatory reform Obamacare and judgment
and as the year came to a close we had
big wins on all four the tax bill was a
huge win reg reform we're seeing every
agency job-killing regulations pulled
back and reduced Obama care is our
biggest unfinished promise but even that
we did repeal the individual mandate I
led the fight to include the individual
mandate repeal and tax reform we got
that done that's a big deal and judges
have been an unmitigated homeroom both
on the Supreme Court the federal courts
of appeals you know in 2017 we confirmed
12 federal appellate judges
that's the most in the first year of a
president's term in history right
all of those are big big victories now
if you look at those every one of those
victories was done through legislative
vehicles that only require 50 votes that
can't be filibuster what I'm urging my
colleagues to do is in 2018 let's
demonstrate that same seriousness of
purpose and let's bring up and vote on
major priorities let's bring up and vote
on making the individual tax cuts
permanent let's make the small business
tax cuts permanent let's vote on a full
repeal or if not major reform of
dodd-frank to free up capital for small
small banks that go and turn to small
businesses let's tackle Obamacare and
and and rescind regulations that are
driving up premiums and expand consumer
freedom all of those we can do if and
here's the critical if we tee up
vehicles that only require 50 votes if
we stay in the world of the Omnibus
where you need 60 votes we're not
getting 9 Democrats right so there are
procedural vehicles that take 50 votes
the two are reconciliation which is how
we pass the tax cut that's how we pass
the Obamacare individual mandate repeal
it's it's how we passed my amendment
expanding college 529s the biggest
federal school choice legislation in
history we passed last year the other
Avenue I've suggested is using NAFTA
renegotiation as a vehicle for
regulatory reform but both of those you
can do with 50 votes and they can't be
filibustered if our leadership is
willing to focus on let's deliver on our
promise so you've been beating this drum
for a long time the Senate leadership
has been unwell in its pursuit of these
priorities I mean this is going all the
way back to your Obamacare filibuster a
quasi filibuster back in 2013 and so the
real question that arises from all of
this is and I want to put you on the
spot here but is it time to replace
Senator McConnell because obviously the
Senate majority leader is the I mean I
think every conservative is listening is
saying okay well we're with you on all
these priorities and we're hearing that
we can do this so who's stopping us we
know Chuck Schumer's against us
we know Democrats are against us so if
McConnell is the guy who's standing in
the way
then what's the deal look I'm not gonna
get into right now sort of leadership
politics and battles what I do think is
we need a Republican leader who is risk
Spahn civ to the will of the Republican
Conference the will of the majority and
ultimately the will of the people who
elect us and I will say among Senate
Republicans there's a generational
divide it a divide between what I call
the young turks and the old bulls the
young turks i define is anyone really
elected 2010 or later and that's a
little more than half our conference
think it's a big chunk of the
republicans in the senate huh
the young turks many of them are pushing
for let's do more there's a real
frustration why are we not delivering on
our promises and i'll confess i'm doing
everything i can to encourage the young
turks come on guys we can actually stand
up and deliver we we can have a real
plan to win not just a plan not to lose
right but a plan to get the kind of
victories we got in 2017 you know I was
deeply enmeshed up to my eyeballs in all
of those battles in 2017 especially the
tax reform battle that was a huge
victory let's learn from our victories
and let's do it again
someone drill down on this for just one
more second and that is you know when it
comes to Senator McConnell you keep
saying leadership I assume his argument
here would be that he's got a fractious
caucus that there are five or six
Republicans you're not willing to go
along with the rest that you say 80% of
the caucus wants to go along with you
that leaves 20% that isn't when you have
a fifty one-vote majority all you need
is two who don't like what you're doing
in order to sing something do you think
that's a real concern or do you think
that that's being exaggerated a little
bit by leadership as an excuse for doing
nothing look I think that's a very real
concern I mean we have fifty-one
Republicans there is massive a massive
ideological gulf it is hard to find an
issue that Susan Collins and Rand Paul
agree mm-hmm I mean that's you know the
Democratic Party their unified they are
all the party of Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders they've all gone so far
left they can unify our party there are
big big big differences that being said
there are a lot of propositions you can
get 50 Republicans for you know that's a
lot of what you know it's interesting
some of the media commentators have been
puzzled at Cruz as consensus make I mean
they sort of view that as a joke yeah
how could Cruz be a consensus maker it's
real simple I believe in this
I didn't run for office just because I
wanted an office in Washington DC I feel
great about it is lousy and you I were
talking about right before the show look
I'm away from my kids every week mm-hmm
I mean this hurts to be away from my
daughters there's only one reason to do
it and it's to make a difference in our
country to get conservative victories to
defend the principles we believe in and
and and so that focus we've got to get
focused on doing that job and there are
lots of things you know before I was in
the Senate I was a Supreme Court
litigator mm-hmm I've settled a lot of
lawsuits the way you settled a lawsuit
you sit down with opposing party you sit
down with with either with the clients
the principles you say all right what do
you want what do you want okay no one's
gonna get everything where's common
ground what do we all agree with there
are a lot of propositions you can get 50
Republicans on board make the individual
tax cuts permanent mhm mm there's a very
simple real victory you know the week
after the tax cut plan passed Bernie
Sanders went on on one of the sunday
shows with Jake Tapper and tapper said
said well look this tax cut cuts the
taxes for virtually every middle-class
taxpayer in America isn't that a good
thing and Bernie says of course the
problem is it's not permanent
I remember this yep and and so I took
that clip i retweeted it to the world I
said Bernie I agree and I've drafted
legislation to make it permanent join me
we can get this done right now now oddly
enough Bernie has been silent it's
putting him in the eye but you know look
that's a proposition we can get 50
Republicans on making the tax cuts
permanent we can get 50 Republicans a
lot of things on Obama care that we can
get expanding health savings accounts we
can get 50 Republicans on that allowing
people to use health savings accounts to
pay for premiums that lets you use
pre-tax dollars that reduces your
effective premium rate 20 to 30 percent
like that mm-hmm
we can get 50 Republicans on that mm-hmm
and and what I'm gonna be teeing up in
the coming weeks I've been having this
conversations with a lot of senators who
agree with me in the next couple of
weeks when we get back in in DC I'm
planning to tee up to the whole
conference and have a conversation
and listen is it really the case that is
a conference we're done we don't have
any ideas anymore we don't want to
accomplish anything I don't believe that
hmm
if there are things we want to get done
and we've got potentially a narrow
window of time nine months to get it
done then let's develop a systematic
plan to accomplish those victories
that's what what our leadership is doing
right now is going to Chuck Schumer and
saying Chuck what do you want to get
done and let's have a plan to get that
accomplished that I think is idiotic and
it's why our basis so unhappen case a
final question for you 2018 obviously
the polls don't look fantastic it's
going to be very very important for
conservatives to get out and do
something about it the question that I
get a lot when I have folks like you
what have senators on is is what are we
supposed to do like the grassroots
conservatives what can they do because
they sit around and they're really
frustrating that frustration bubbles to
the top through the tea parties or
through Trump or whatever it is but then
they feel constantly let down so what
can they do right now to help foster
what you're talking about what can they
do the other to that and sit around and
grouse about it if you look at 2018 2018
I think is gonna be a turnout election
it's not a persuasion election you the
Democrats agree with this by the way if
you look at how the Democrats are
behaving they have decided that that the
set of swing voters of voters who are
gonna show up in a vote in November but
haven't decided if they're democrat or
republican that that's essentially a
null set that doesn't gives this yep so
for the last 15 months what we've seen
is the demise of the moderate Democrat
where even the so-called moderate
democrats the joe Manchin's the heidi
hyde camps they're voting records are
identical or virtually identical to
chuck schumer and Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders they're all tacking hard
left their objective is simple turnout
the far left and the far left they're
energized they're angry and they hate
the president it is their motivating
force and rage we're going to see in
November record Democratic turnout in
all 50 states is going to shatter
records the question that will determine
whether 2018 is a good election where we
win three four or five Senate seats we
come back with a real functioning
majority in the Senate or whether we get
blown out and have Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer as the leaders in Congress
is going to come entirely down to
conservative turnout the states that are
up in 2018 there are more conservatives
and liberals if conservatives show up
we'll do well my state in Texas I'm up
for re-election in Texas we're facing
Democrats who are energized we just had
earlier this month a Democratic primary
where Democratic turnout was up 100
percent four years ago was 500,000 this
year it was a million now fortunately we
had 1.5 million Republicans come out so
we we turned out conservatives but we
got to do that in November mm-hmm I'm
facing an opponent congressman baitoey
Roarke right who's running hard left
he's running on open borders he's
running on aggressive gun control he's
running on socialized medicine he's
running on raising taxes and on the far
left they're raising money like crazy
my Democratic opponent is out raising me
well and what happens every time the
president says something tweets
something thousands of Bernie Sanders
leftists their heads explode and they go
online and they give fifty or hundred
bucks to every Democrat they can find so
one of the things the folks listening to
you look the other side is energized and
engaged for my campaign I'd encourage
you come to our website it's Ted Cruz or
Ted Cruz org sign up volunteer speak out
contribute we need the resources to
mobilize conservatives and then I'd
encourage one of the beauties of the
modern age of the social media age is
you don't have to be you know been
you've got a show you've got you've got
a media platform you know every one of
your listeners has a platform also every
one of your listeners can engage their
friends mobilize their friends make them
laugh make them care every person
listening to this show I hope number one
will contribute at Ted Cruz org but
number two will focus on energizing and
turning out conservatives for November
and simultaneously holding Republicans
accountable in Washington guys deliver
on your promises get more conservative
victories to give everyone a reason to
come vote well senator Cruz thanks so
much for stopping by I really appreciate
it's always great to see you and of
course we go all the way back to the
david Dewhurst days it's good to see you
know obviously how prominent
become and we can only hope that you
continue to be in a leadership position
hopefully that grows over time
thanks so much senator for stopping by
Thank You Ben well it's great to have
senator Cruz on so meanwhile and there
again there's been a lot of talk about
the prominence of Roseanne show Roseanne
showed an incredibly well last night and
the culture wars are still raging people
are wondering why it is that the two
sides are at each other's throats one of
the reasons the two sides are at each
other's throats is because the
journalistic community has really failed
in its basic duty to provide us with a
common set of facts I don't talk about
that in just a second but first you're
gonna have to go over to Daily wire and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
the rest of this show live and get the
rest of clayvin show live there are some
Knowles's show live be part of our
mailbag that we are doing on Friday here
and whenever we do the conversation you
get to send in questions all of that
plus the annual subscription gets you
this the greatest in all beverage
vessels leftist ears hot or cold mug it
is just glorious in all of its various
permutations you get that with the
annual subscription which is in fact
less expensive than the monthly
subscription also please if you want to
listen later go over to iTunes or
YouTube please subscribe but please
leave this review it always helps us we
are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
one of the reasons the country is so
divided right now obviously is because
the way journalists have done their
business is quite obviously terrible and
it is true across the spectrum okay it's
true from right to left the media has
just on a garbage job at providing facts
and then logic now listen I am an
opinion host right I make this very
clear every single day I am a guy with
an opinion and particular positions what
I tried to do however is present you
with a certain number of facts and then
I try to connect all those facts and
lead to my conclusion so you can try to
figure out where in my argument I'm
going wrong if you disagree with me what
is the fact that I miss stating where
exactly am I making a leap between fact
a in fact B in order to get to
conclusion see that's what I try to do
on the show so that we can take this
journey together and think along with
one another but that's not something
that's happening in the media and the
media seem okay with this the reason I'm
talking about this is because Michael
Woolf was the author of fire and fury
and has been widely discredited at this
point he made a series of comments to a
student newspaper at Vassar College
which was his alma mater and here's what
he had to say it's an amazing statement
quote I am an observer
i investigate nothing all I do is look
and write what I see in what I hear and
my job which has nothing to do with
truth is to take what I see and what I
hear and write that in a way that
readers can come as close as possible as
close as I came to the experience of
doing this I want to be able to turn
what I see into something that a reader
says oh I see that too that line there
which has nothing to do with truth is
the key line and right now in media
media coverage has nothing to do with
truth which is one of the reasons why I
think people are so polarized because
you can view one website and view a
second website and come up with two
completely different visions of the
world but not only that two completely
different versions of the facts and it's
happening on all sides on the one side
for example you have CNN and CNN had a
team panel where teens were debating
guns and again this was CNN's way of
propping up particular teens I in order
to in order to generate support for gun
control
what would you consider success because
of the movement an assault weapons ban
handguns are perfectly okay that fits
into the Second Amendment we we don't
need people walking around with ar-15s
why are you telling everyone out there
in America that you can't own a gun for
your protection you know I'm in fear
walking around this
So Solid TV there from CNN you can't
understand what anyone is saying but the
point here is to have on a bunch of
young students like a Linda Ellerbee
show on Nick jr. in order to in order to
discuss these issues the whole point
here is of course to particular to
produce a particular agenda this is what
CNN has been doing for weeks on the gun
issues so the media coverage of this has
been just egregious and then on the
right you have people like Alex Jones
who are out there promoting the most
radical version of critique first of all
you've seen people who are putting out
false false hoods open falsehoods about
the parklands students who they disagree
with we don't do that on this program we
just play their quotes and then we talk
about why they're wrong which i think is
a different thing but Alex Jones is Alex
Jones and he doesn't Alex Jones thing
and a lot of his followers think this
kind of stuff so he actually dubbed a
Hitler speech over footage of david
hagman i think david hog he's a pretty
terrible advocate for his position I
think that he's wrong about pretty much
everything but this is just a monster
t'v of the gap that's happening in
journalism right now authoritarianism is
always about youth marches here we go
can't see this he's actually putting
video of David Hogg over that audio of
Adolf Hitler and putting it in black and
white now is any of this designed to
actually get to the truth is any of this
designed to actually just IAEA is any of
this designed to enrich the country or
get us to a point where we can have
discussions now this is my problem with
with everything that's happening in the
media right now from Hollywood from
shows like Roseanne to what's happening
now it's Jones to CNN there is no
attempt to even get to a common basis of
fact so that we can have a discussion if
there is no common basis of facts there
is no discussion to be had there cannot
be a discussion if this is the case it's
just it's it's absurd yeah and and again
this is happening not just listen you
wouldn't expect better from Alex Jones
because Alex Jones Alex Jones right I
mean the guy is so supplements and I
unbutton my shirt oh my god look at oh
my god I'm not wearing a shirt no that's
Alex Jones a shtick but you do expect
better from CNN you would assume right I
mean I think we have a right to expect
writer from CNN that's how they pitched
themselves but they were the same people
were putting on Michael Wolf every night
I mean Jake Tapper admirably was going
after Michael Wolf he was one of the few
surely everybody else in the media MSNBC
CNN all the networks they were giving
Michael Wolff enormous credibility and
he says he has nothing to do with the
truth and then you wonder why it is that
there seem to be alternative realities
in the world of politics that's why
there are alternative realities in the
world of politics now meanwhile it's
there's some updates on the storm he's
Daniels front it's just getting it's
just getting tawdry at this point you
know I love as he cut over on CNN
Headline News but she is making the case
that Melania should leave Trump I here's
what she had to say about it Melania may
not have a political career to consider
but as first lady she is an inherently
important figure in American politics
and women are watching particularly
young women Melania should do for this
generation of girls what Hillary Clinton
did not do for mine and leave her jerk
of a husband okay so I I have a couple
of critiques I disagree with se that
Melania should leave Trump for a couple
of reasons
well then she can if she wants but there
are a couple reasons I don't think that
Melania should lead from but the reason
that I'm bringing this up is because
it's pretty obvious that the stormy
Daniel stuff has just become gossip TV
at this point now here's why I disagree
with with se for a couple of reasons one
Melania knew what she was getting into
in the first place she was wife number
three and she was having an affair with
Trump while he was married to wife
number two so it's not like Melania
didn't know was coming and she'd been
very obvious about this she was asked at
one point whether Trump would have
married her if she wasn't beautiful and
she said what I have married Trump if
you weren't rich I mean this is a very
transactional relationship everybody
knows this who's been watching it second
they have a kid together okay divorce is
never good for the kid and Melania again
knew what she was getting into when she
had a kid with with Donald Trump so yeah
I disagree with se but the point here is
again this this conversation has
basically degraded he can see it on a
CNN panel again CNN doing yeoman's
journalist work this would be clip 9 a
panel going off the rails about storming
Daniels you were on this very air and
this very network and you know you said
barack obama doesn't love America
what's the difference is all Jerry
Springer garbage it's all Jerry Springer
garbage we can stop it there I don't
have to listen to this it's all Jerry
Springer nonsense and the Jerry Springer
nonsense devolves into basically people
tribally siding up right so the CNN did
an interview with a bunch of female
Trump supporters and they asked you know
what do you think now that all these
allegations have come out about stormy
Daniels and the female Trump supporters
basically said listen you guys are gonna
tell me what you want me to hear and I
don't believe anything you have to say
okay here's what that panel looked like
you could be pushed by somebody else
right and so I think the thing is is
you're looking for a way to impeach my
president that I worked very hard for
okay and I think there are a lot of
Trump supporters who feel that way again
because the media have failed to do a
good job in policing themselves and
simply telling the facts right they can
give us their conclusion but they have
to tell us the facts first okay quick
thing I like and then a quick thing I
hate and then I want to talk pass over
for about 30 seconds here so things I
like number one I just had the thing I
like today is that Bernie Sanders
inspired an actual circus clown to run
for office this is not actually a joke
so according to Emily Zanotti over at
Daily wire steven lamothe is a former
clown with the Ringling Brothers Circus
and a former volunteer with both Barack
Obama and Bernie Sanders his campaigns
he also happens to snag the Democratic
nomination in South Carolina's fifth
congressional district and he's gonna
take on Ralph Norman in November he
promises that he will be a better clown
in office than the current clowns in
office he says they joked that the
President and Congress are all clowns
well my professional opinion they are
the worst clowns I have ever seen so
pretty spectacular stuff of course a
Bernie Sanders inspired clown is running
for office because he is right I mean he
is right okay our politics is filled
with clowns okay time for a quick thing
that I hate so
so Heineken has now released an ad and
then they pulled the ad I'm gonna show
you the ad and then we'll try to figure
out exactly what's wrong with the ad
it's a bartender who's looking down at a
beautiful woman at the end of the at the
end of the bar and he's sliding her a
he's sliding her a beer and it soars
past a bunch of different people it sort
his past is obvious in a part topical
place sort of past him so a couple of
black folks and then finally it arrives
at the end and it's a light beer right
and it says sometimes later is better at
ninety nine calories okay and the woman
at the end of the bar can we pause it on
her because go back for a second is
there a way that we can pause it on her
because I want to see what she actually
looks like okay stop it so this is not a
white woman right this looks like in an
ethnic woman right jokes maybe Asian is
that right I mean if you can say Mathis
what's your take this is this obviously
it's not just a Russian lady right I
mean this this lady looks like maybe
latina it's kind of kind of hard to tell
what ethnicity she is but she's
obviously a non wasp extraction right
but the so what was the criticism of
this the criticism of this it a it's an
ad for Heineken like Mathis did you see
anything wrong with this ad was there a
problem with this ad when it said is
light better did you did you see it okay
so the problem with this ad is that the
ad shows the beer sliding past three
black people and then arriving at a non
black woman at the end and so the idea
is that this is a racist ad that the ad
is saying that lighter skin is better
and that's why he's sliding the beer to
her okay if we've become this stupid in
this sensitive you really think that
people made this ad we're saying the
light skin is better really that was the
implication of the ad when you have a
couple of people who look like maybe
they're of Spanish extraction sliding
beers to each other that's that's what
you got from that ad yeah you may be a
little bit crazy if this is how far you
are willing to go in the name of
political correctness okay so but today
is Wednesday and that means that
normally we do a little bit of Bible
talk well the Bible talk for today comes
courtesy of the fact that this weekend
begins the holiday of Passover which is
I believe my favorite holiday is either
that or Sukkot which is the one where we
sit in the booths and one of the things
that people need to know about the
holiday of Passover which is of course
all about the Exodus is the Exodus is
not just a universal vague thing so
people in politics have used the exodus
story to justify virtually anything
we've heard it used to justify the civil
rights movement I think appropriately
used to justify the gay right
movement I think wildly inappropriately
and to use the two the transgender
movement again they let my people go
line is the one that's usually used
right Moses goes to Pharaoh and he says
let my people go and this is supposed to
be the end of the story but this is not
the end of the story folks okay that
ignores a couple of things about the
Exodus story one the rest of let my
people go
the phrase does not end it let my people
go okay what God actually says to Moses
is he says go to Pharaoh and say to him
quote thus says the Lord let my people
go that they may serve me hey every time
it says let my people go in the Bible it
is followed with that they may serve me
in the wilderness or that they may serve
me okay the whole point is that God is
saying people have to be freed of
earthly tyranny so they can submit
themselves to the yoke of heaven right
that is the point of the Bible the point
of the Bible is that God is the boss and
you are not the boss and liberty is
necessary so that you can pursue virtue
not so that you can pursue vice and
Western civilization seems to have
forgotten that we seem to think that let
my people go is the end of the
invocation now once you say let my
people go
there's no further moral duty right no
duty attaches to the right and once you
sever so that they may serve me then let
my people go basically just means leave
me alone but it turns out that people
then impose other sorts of earthly
tyranny because what they suggest is
that now in order for me to let your
people go that means that you have to
invade my church and tell me what to do
it means that you have to invade my home
and tell me how to raise my child let my
people go so they may serve me is the
root and branch I believe of the Western
civilized thought which is there are
rights and there are duties and these
two things are inherently connected
there are rights from government there
are rights that you have that pre-exists
the states those come from God and those
exist so that we can seek Him right that
is that the without a religious
fundamental moral basis to the United
States Rights tend to disappear into a
miasma of libertinism
and that's what all the founders
believed Adams thought that Washington
thought that that's the message of the
Exodus the Exodus is very specific to a
specific people who are supposed to be a
light unto the nations it wasn't just
God decided I'm gonna take one nation
out of another nation and then I'm just
gonna leave them alone and tell them do
whatever the hell they want that was not
the purpose the culmination of the
Exodus story is it Sinai with with the
acceptance of the Torah by the Jewish
people that's the purpose of the story
it's to fulfill a and earthly promise in
terms of the land that the Jews are
supposed to inherit that God is a
fulfill our promises that he keeps his
promises that he is true to you right
that is the message message number one
of the
and message number two is that you must
be true to him as well because your
freedom is contingent upon you doing
your virtuous duty okay so that is the
real message of Passover don't believe
all the other cheap hype about it's just
about let my people go because again
there are submissions that attach once
you have freedom okay we'll be back here
tomorrow which moon with much much more
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alec singhara audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018